- When scholars look back
on the 2016 election,
one of the strangest,
most befuddling things,
though by no means the strangest
or most befuddling things,
will be that this guy was
the putative front runner
for the democratic nominee
for the president of the United States.
And that's when things got weird.
(victorious music)
Michael Avenatti, the
attorney who rose to fame
for his representation of Stormy Daniels
in lawsuits against President Trump
has now been convicted and sentenced
to two and a half years in prison
for attempting to extort Nike.
And his legal journey is just beginning.
By all accounts, it looks like
he's going to go to prison
for a lot longer before
all of this is done.
In Avenatti's journey
from litigator for the resistance
to disgraced heel of the legal profession
is one of the steepest falls
that many can remember.
And his legal troubles are far from over.
In December, he will stand trial
for allegedly stealing
$300,000 from Daniels.
Right now, he is currently
on trial in Los Angeles
on charges that he embezzled
$10 million from five clients.
During jury selection,
Avenatti fired his lawyer
and got the green light
to represent himself.
You might think that this
is a pretty standard move,
but believe me,
defendants representing
themselves in a criminal trial
is the stuff of bad movies,
like this one starring
Vin Diesel with hair.
- Have you had any legal experience?
- I've been in prison half my life.
Sometimes I think I had
too much legal experience.
- But you guys, this scene
actually happened in real life.
Avenatti told the judge
he was qualified to represent himself
because he had just participated
in his own criminal trial.
He told the judge,
"I've made appearances in less than five,
maybe two or three
criminal cases, Your Honor.
I have never tried a criminal case."
And then he also mentioned
his participation
in the Nike extortion case
in the Southern district of New York.
When the judge asked about
Avenatti's participation
in criminal sentencing,
he again brought up the
time a few weeks ago
when he was sentenced to two
and a half years in prison.
This is literally a joke
from "The Simpsons".
- And as for your case, don't you worry.
I've argued in front of
every judge in the state,
often as a lawyer.
(sipping soda)
- Of course,
legal warnings about the folly
of representing yourself,
date back all the way to 1682.
There's a reason for the saying,
"A man who represents himself
has a fool for a client."
And today we're going
to answer the question
just how foolish is Michael Avenatti?
The answer, very.
- It appears to be amateur hour.
- So who is this guy, anyway?
Any discussion of the Avenatti saga
has to start with that question.
And Michael Avenatti was not well-known
outside of California legal circles
until he burst onto the scene
by suing Donald Trump on
behalf of Stormy Daniels.
Avenatti's willingness to opine on Trump
made him an attractive
guest for cable news hits.
In fact, he made over 250
television news appearances
in less than two years.
And then he represented Julie Swetnick
in a misconduct claim
against Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh,
once again putting
himself front and center.
But not everyone was an Avenatti fan.
He got into an argument
with Michael Cohen's lawyer,
whom he derided for representing a felon.
This is astoundingly bad
commentary by Avenatti.
Not to point out the obvious,
but now he is such a felon
in need of representation
though perhaps his philosophy
is why he wants to represent himself.
And Avenatti got into frequent arguments
with just about everyone,
including well-known former
prosecutor, Ken White,
who you might know as Popehat on Twitter.
And after one of their Twitter rows,
Avenatti called up White to yell and curse
and proclaim himself
"The greatest lawyer who ever lawyered."
which of course is incredibly ironic
given his current location.
- That is not a very smart guy.
- Though many people
thought he was a charlatan from the start,
millions of people were fooled.
His pugnacious TV appearances
made him a popular Twitter personality
and earned him speaking
engagements all over the country.
At one point in 2017,
Avenatti announced he was
considering running for president.
He even visited Iowa
to prepare for the presidential primary.
Michael Avenatti
looked like a man who
was king of the world,
flying around the world on private jets
and owning his own race car company.
But behind the scenes,
Avenatti was already cracking.
Let's start at the beginning
of Michael Avenatti's legal career.
In the year 2000,
Michael Avenatti graduated
first in his class
from the George Washington
University School of Law.
Just three years later,
GW established the
Michael J. Avenatti Award
for Excellence in Pre-Trial
and Trial Advocacy.
Getting an award named
after you so quickly
means two things.
One, you are making a lot of money,
and two, you are donating
a lot of that money,
though Avenatti has always had a gift
for scrapping and digging up dirt.
Before his law career,
he worked for former Obama Chief of Staff,
Rahm Emanuel's consulting firm
where he researched the backgrounds
of Democratic and Republican candidates
looking for the details
candidates could use
to bring down their opponents.
But after law school,
Avenatti moved to California
and became a well-regarded
plaintiff's attorney.
In 2008, Avenatti won a $32
million judgment against KPMG
for audit malpractice.
In 2014, he achieved a $80
million class action settlement
with the Los Angeles Cemetery,
which dumped the remains of
Jewish people into a mass grave.
And in 2017, he secured
a $454 million judgment
against Kimberly Clark for
defective surgical gowns.
Although Avenatti claims
to have won one billion
dollars for his clients,
many of those verdicts were
substantially reduced on appeal.
Still by any measure,
Avenatti had been a very
successful trial lawyer.
This was enough to get him the
attention of the legal world,
but outside of it, no
one really knew his name.
In 2015, he had fewer than
600 Twitter followers,
most of whom were lawyers and law firms.
And despite his professional success,
Avenatti has never been able
to keep his nose for conflict
from interfering with his
business and professional lives.
He fought with a former law partner
resulting in an order requiring him
to pay one non-equity partner
$15 million in back pay.
He then was ordered to pay $4.85 million
for failing to pay a debt
to a former colleague.
And eventually his law firm
was evicted from its Orange County offices
for allegedly failing
to pay months of rent.
And Avenatti's troubles
extended to his other
business connections.
In 2013, Avenatti purchased
a Seattle coffee chain
called Tully's.
His partner in the endeavor
was McDreamy himself,
no, not Dr. Mike,
original recipe McDreamy Patrick Dempsey.
Dempsey actually sued
to back out of the sale just months later
alleging that Avenatti had taken on
a two million dollar
loan without telling him.
Avenatti purchased the coffee company
through a larger entity
called Global Baristas.
Global Baristas struggled to
pay suppliers and landlords
and had more than 45
lawsuits filed against it.
The company lost a lawsuit with Curry,
then a battle with the IRS
and then closed down all
of the Tully's stores.
While his businesses were beset
by litigation and tax problems,
Avenatti was maintaining
a jetset lifestyle.
He owned a $19 million mansion,
numerous expensive race
cars and two private jets.
But then the bad times came.
They say bad things happen in threes
and that's certainly been
true for Michael Avenatti.
So let's look at the
three most recent cases.
First is the Nike extortion case.
Avenatti was arrested in March of 2019
minutes after tweeting
that he had scheduled
a press conference to,
"Disclose a major high
school/basketball scandal
perpetrated by Nike
that we have uncovered."
Avenatti was trying to
get ahead of the fallout
from federal charges they accused Avenatti
of trying to extort Nike.
The charges stem from a meeting
set up by Avenatti with Nike
that took place on March 19th, 2019.
The meeting was held under the pretense
that Avenatti represented
a youth basketball coach
who had information that Nike employees
paid the families of high school athletes.
Avenatti's client was Gary Franklin,
the coach of a youth basketball team
called California Supreme.
The team competed in the AAU leagues,
which are a hotbed of college
basketball recruiting.
Major sneaker companies like
Reebok and Nike and Adidas
all hang around with the
players and college scouts
creating an atmosphere
of general shadiness.
And Coach Franklin testified
that he was bullied by Nike executives
who forced him to make illicit payments
to top high school basketball
players and their families.
Franklin said that in 2018,
the company ended its
sponsorship of the team
and he turned to Avenatti for help.
During this meeting,
Avenatti demanded that Nike
pay Franklin $1.5 million.
Avenatti also wanted Nike
to pay him and his co-counsel,
famed defense lawyer, Mark
Geragos, $15 to $25 million
to conduct a internal
investigation on Nike's behalf.
Avenatti, who allegedly had a debt
of over $11 million at the time,
said that he planned an announcement
on the eve of Nike's
quarterly earnings call
and at the start of the
annual NCAA tournament
if they did not agree to
the terms of this agreement.
Avenatti was betting that
Nike would rather pay him off
rather than suffer the PR hit,
which Avenatti predicted
would tank Nike's stock
by billions of dollars.
As Avenatti put it in their meeting,
"The company will die,
not die, but they are going to incur
cut after cut after cut.
And that's what's going to happen
as soon as this thing becomes public."
Unfortunately for Avenatti,
Nike's lawyers who are
some of the best paid
and most well-regarded
attorneys in the country,
were not cowed and instead
called the U.S. attorney's office.
Nike's lawyers asked
Avenatti to repeat his offer.
Was he really saying he should
get at least $15 million
when his client was only
getting $1.5 million?
Stupidly, not sensing a trap,
Avenatti said he sure was.
- [Michael] But I'm not (bleep) around.
- So why was this an
incredibly foolish move?
Because the law of extortion.
The Department of Justice has
traditionally been cautious
about charging attorneys with extortion.
That's because it's perfectly legal
to negotiate a settlement for a client.
Most civil cases settle.
Lawyers usually kick things off
with a demand letter
followed by negotiations
and sometimes a mediation.
It's legal to make demands in
the context of negotiations,
even crazy demands for lots of money.
So when do a lawyer's
demands become extortion?
Well, federal extortion is
covered by the Hobbs Act.
And this is a law
that makes extortion
and blackmail illegal.
And the Hobbs Act defines extortion as,
"The obtaining of property from another,
with his consent,
induced by wrongful use of
actual or threatened force,
violence or fear under
color of official right."
Now the line between extortion
and legal settlement negotiations
is not well demarcated.
A threat of litigation is
generally not considered criminal.
This is true even if the
lawyer's threats to sue
are supported by false testimony
or fabricated evidence.
Federal courts have held that if a lawsuit
is not pursued exclusively
by lawful methods,
the threat of litigation
might constitute extortion.
And the courts look at many factors,
including whether an entity
like Nike was more afraid
that its actual illegal
conduct would be exposed
or more afraid of publicity
from illegitimate threats.
And if that sounds murky to you,
that's because it really is.
Lawyers have a professional responsibility
to zealously represent their clients
and Avenatti argued that
he was doing just that
against a company that
had committed wrongdoing.
However, if a lawyer starts to stray
from their responsibility
to their clients,
that's a huge red flag.
And this is where
Avenatti ran into trouble.
When a lawyer uses methods like publicity,
grossly exaggerated demands
and false information,
a negotiation can turn
into an illegal shakedown.
And remember, Avenatti wasn't asking Nike
to pay the fees Franklin incurred.
He wanted Nike to pay him and
Geragos millions of dollars
to act as internal investigators.
Federal prosecutors
said Avenatti took advantage of Franklin,
hoping to use his client
to pay off his massive personal debt.
Coach Franklin said he
wanted his team back
and two Nike executives fired,
but Avenatti ignored what
his client actually wanted.
Instead Avenatti started asking
Nike to pay him personally.
And on top of that,
he apparently didn't disclose
these payment demands
to Franklin.
The coach also said he knew nothing
about Avenatti's plan to
hold a press conference.
And this is of course strikingly similar
to how Avenatti allegedly
handled litigation with Daniels,
ignoring her stated goals
while pursuing his own.
The jury obviously was
swayed by the FBI recordings
where Avenatti pressured
Nike to agree to his terms
or suffer the consequences.
- [Michael] And if you don't
want to do that, we're done.
I'm not (bleep) around with this
and I'm not continuing to play games.
You guys know enough now to
know you got a serious problem
and it's worth more in exposure to me
to just blow the lid on this thing.
A few million dollars doesn't
move the needle for me.
I'm just being really frank with you.
- Obviously the emphasis
of the phone calls
appeared to be what was good
for Avenatti personally,
rather than what was right for his client.
And the jury probably also
considered Avenatti's threat
to take $10 billion off
of Nike's market cap
by disclosing Franklin's allegations.
This was construed as a grossly
exaggerated economic threat.
And at the conclusion
of the three week trial,
a verdict by a unanimous
jury found Michael Avenatti
guilty on all counts.
The jury didn't buy the
defense's closing argument that"
"In the words of Nike itself,
he went in there to 'Just
Do It' for his client."
At Avenatti's sentencing,
he appeared tearful and apologetic.
He said,
"I and I alone have destroyed my career,
my relationships and my life."
And he continued,
"Your Honor,
I've learned that all the fame, notoriety
and money in the world is meaningless.
TV and Twitter, Your Honor, mean nothing."
Amen to that.
Still, this tactic was
probably a good one.
He seemed to be getting
reasonably good legal advice
because the sentence
that he ultimately got
was significantly lower
than what the prosecutors
wanted him to get.
The judge sentenced him to
two and a half years in prison
and the judge cited two things
for the downward departure
from the guidelines,
the horrible conditions
in the Manhattan jail
where Avenatti spent more than 100 days
and the absence of Mark Geragos.
Prosecutors declined to charge Geragos,
even though he attended all
the meetings with Avenatti
and played good cop to Avenatti's bad cop.
The judge called Geragos,
"A central figure in
the criminal conduct."
The judge listened to the Avenatti tapes
and concluded that Geragos' conduct
simply wasn't distinguishable
from Avenatti.
And that is an interesting question.
But that is just the tip
of the Avenatti iceberg
because he faces continued
legal jeopardy in California,
where he used to primarily practice.
Avenatti is now on trial
for defrauding clients and
absconding with payments to them,
specifically a federal
grand jury indicted Avenatti
on 36 counts of fraud,
perjury, failure to pay taxes,
embezzlement and other financial crimes.
The indictment alleges
that Avenatti stole
several million dollars
from five clients
and used a variety of Shell
companies and bank accounts
to cover up his crimes.
And the crimes range
from stealing from a mentally
ill paraplegic on disability
who won a four million settlement
in a suit against Los Angeles County
to a $2.5 million settlement
that was primarily used for
the purchase of a private jet
allegedly.
Now, Avenatti is now
acting as his own lawyer
in these criminal cases,
meaning that he is literally
going to cross-examine former clients
who now accuse him of stealing from them.
For example, on the first day of trial,
Avenatti confronted Jeffrey Johnson,
who Avenatti represented
in a lawsuit over injuries he sustained
while jumping from an elevated floor
in a Los Angeles jail.
Johnson tried to kill himself twice
after bullying and attacks
by inmates and corrections officers.
Avenatti negotiated a four
million dollar settlement
with Los Angeles County,
but the money was put in a medical trust
that Avenatti controlled.
Johnson accused Avenatti
of draining nearly all
of the four million dollars in settlements
while paying Johnson
roughly $1,900 a month
to lull him into thinking
his money was safe.
Though perversely, Avenatti's
cross-examination of Johnson
gives us a good window
on what made him a good trial
lawyer in the first place.
Avenatti got Johnson to admit
that he hired Avenatti
to get him out of jail
by any means necessary
and that Avenatti delivered.
Johnson admitted
that Avenatti got him
released to a medical center
and that Avenatti paid
the bill for all of it.
Johnson admits that the care center
costs several thousand dollars a month
and that Avenatti paid for that as well.
And all of this sounds like Avenatti
did real work on the
case and he probably did,
but as the prosecution
established on direct examination,
Avenatti asked Johnson to
sign a peculiar document
attesting to his ethics
and great work as a lawyer.
The document says Avenatti is,
"an exceptional, honest
and ethical attorney
and I feel fortunate to
have had him represent me."
There's just one giant
problem with this attestation.
Avenatti had been charged with
stealing Johnson's settlement
the day before he asked
Johnson to sign the document
and Johnson apparently didn't know
that Avenatti had been accused
of embezzling the funds.
At any rate, if Avenatti's convicted
of all of the charges in
the California indictment,
Avenatti could face many
more years in prison
on top of the two and a half years,
he already got from the
New York prosecutors,
which brings us to the
Stormy Daniels case.
Later this year, Avenatti will stand trial
yet a third time
bringing his time in the
public eye full circle.
Avenatti will have to defend himself
against charges of wire fraud
and aggravated identity theft
in the case involving Stormy Daniels,
though, ironically, by this time,
he'll have quite a lot of experience
as a criminal defense attorney,
meaning he might actually
know what he's doing
this time around.
Avenatti is accused
of using misrepresentations
and a fraudulent document
purporting to bear the
name of Stormy Daniels
and her own signature
to convince her literary agent
to send him the money
the agent owed Daniel's
for a book advance.
Once Avenatti fraudulently
obtained the money,
he allegedly used it
to pay for typical attorney expenses,
such as restaurants,
meal delivery services
and car payments on his Ferrari.
When Daniel's began to
question where her money was,
Avenatti lied
that he was still trying to
obtain it from the publisher
and then when he finally paid her,
he did so by improperly diverting
funds from another source.
This is the same kind of alleged conduct
that Avenatti pulled with Patrick Dempsey
and the California clients.
If Avenatti isn't disbarred
as a result of the prior two cases,
if he's found guilty in
this particular case,
he absolutely will be disbarred
from ever practicing law again,
and Avenatti potentially
faces a maximum of 20 years
for the wire fraud case
in addition to a mandatory
two year prison sentence
for the aggravated identity theft charge.
Oh, and of course, it
won't surprise you to learn
that Avenatti wasn't shooting
straight with the IRS either.
During the commission of
all of these alleged crimes,
Avenatti had a four year streak
where he did not file
personal income tax returns.
And three of those years,
he did not file tax returns
for both of his law firms.
In addition, he allegedly lied to the IRS
about pocketing nearly $2.4
million in taxes withheld
from the paychecks of employees
of Global Baristas U.S.,
which operated the now
defunct Tully's Coffee stores.
And in the California case,
the jury has already heard testimony
from three other former clients.
Avenatti allegedly stiffed
YouTuber Michelle Phan,
a makeup artist,
out of at least four million dollars.
Avenatti's former paralegal testified
that she was instructed to
give Phan the run-around
on an eight million dollar
wire transfer of funds
that belonged to Phan.
Eventually, Avenatti told the paralegal
to send a partial payment
of four million dollars.
But Avenatti allegedly embezzled
the other four million dollars.
Additionally, Gregory
Barela alleges that Avenatti
ran his law firm like a Ponzi scheme,
accusing him of stealing settlement funds
and then trying to lend him the funds
at a 10% interest rate.
Avenatti handled litigation for Barela,
securing him a settlement
of over two million dollars,
but in January 2018,
a third party started paying funds
into a client trust
fund managed by Avenatti
for him to pass on to Barela.
But instead of doing so,
Avenatti allegedly told Barela
that the third party had never
paid the settlement money.
When Barilla hired new lawyers
to get the settlement funds,
the third party told him
that they had already
paid money to Avenatti.
Alexis Gardner hired
Avenatti to represent her
in a lawsuit against her ex-boyfriend,
NBA Basketball player Hassan Whiteside.
Avenatti negotiated a settlement
of around three million
dollars in early 2017.
He told Gardner
that the money would be doled
out in monthly increments,
but during 2018, the
monthly payments stopped.
Avenatti assured Gardner
that he was hounding Whiteside every week
about missing payments.
However, prosecutors say that in reality,
Whiteside's financial team
had already paid Avenatti a lump sum
of $2.7 million a year earlier.
They alleged that Avenatti spent the money
on private airplanes and other luxuries.
If these allegations are true,
Avenatti has committed fraud
and broken many of the rules
of professional conduct for lawyers.
When a lawyer receives
money meant for a client,
the lawyer doesn't own that money.
That's common sense.
The lawyer has to keep that in trust.
ABA Model Rule 1.5 covers
this exact scenario,
"A lawyer shall hold property
of clients or third-persons
that is in the lawyer's possession,
in connection with their representation,
separate from the lawyer's own property.
Funds shall be kept in a separate account,
maintained in the state
where the lawyer's office is situated
or elsewhere with the
consent of the client
or third-person."
Although the rules of professional conduct
are not criminal laws,
when lawyers misuse client funds,
criminal charges may follow
if those actions rise to the
level of criminal conduct.
And here, if these allegations are true,
that standard is definitely met.
Prosecutors accused Avenatti
of lying to Gardner and Barela
about the structure of their payments.
The model rules cover this as well,
"Upon receiving funds or other property
in which a client or
third-person has an interest,
a lawyer shall promptly notify
the client or third-person.",
which Avenatti allegedly did not do.
The bottom line here is that
Avenatti is going to prison
for a very long time
regardless of the outcome
of these California cases.
So he'll definitely need some new hobbies
to keep him occupied.
He'd really benefit from Mary
Andrew's Skillshare class,
"Drawing as Self-Discover:
5 Ways to Start"
because Avenatti's gonna have
a ton of time for painting
where he's going.
Or he could use Emma Gannon's class,
"Finding Fulfillment:
Using Pivots to Power
Your Creative Career"
because Michael Avenatti
is going to have to pivot hard away from
actually being a lawyer.
Skillshare, today's sponsor,
has classes on almost everything,
from video to music, to
business and entrepreneurship.
It's one of the world's largest
online learning communities
with tens of thousands of
classes on absolutely everything.
So it's the best place for a former lawyer
to get a new start.
So if you'd like to try out Skillshare,
the first 1,000 Legal
Eagles to use my link below,
will get a free trial
of Skillshare Premium.
And for a limited time,
this trial is for an entire month,
not just 14 days as usual.
And after that trial ends,
Skillshare is still way more affordable
than most online learning platforms.
So just click on this link
that's onscreen right now
to get a free trial of Skillshare.
Plus, clicking on this link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there,
click on this other link for
all my other real law reviews
or I'll see you in court.